last week our school board uh here in
nashville decided to instate a universal
mask mandate for all students and all
staff and anyone else who sets foot
inside the building on monday the board
outlined the punishments that will be
meted out to any child who dares to show
his bare face on school grounds actually
there are many other offenses a student
might commit beyond the indecent
exposure of his nose and mouth as the
tennessean reports the offenses include
quote refusing to wear a mask or
maintain social distancing leaving a
designated area or intentionally
exchanging bodily fluids such as
coughing or sneezing are considered
violations of the district's protocols
coughing and sneezing now count as
misconduct
i'm sorry not coughing and sneezing only
intentional coughing and sneezing
intentional coughing and sneezing in the
first degree with malice a forethought
that's what we're really worried about
you know
how do you distinguish between
intentional coughing and sneezing and
accidental coughing and sneezing
these details are not provided which
means that it will be up to the schools
to decide whether any particular
incident of coughing qualifies as an
infraction or not
and if it is an offense the offender
better not make a habit of it because
the consequences can be quite dire more
from the tennis scene it says
students who violate the district's
protocols could face discipline
including a student teacher conference
for the first offense let's stop there
for a second
uh i
i'm trying to imagine a student-teacher
conference
where the where the where the uh
you know
sitting down talking about a cough
how long is that conversation gonna be
and then second offense is a
parent-teacher conference so now the
parents are going to sit down
and you have to the student there and
everyone's sitting down very solemnly
and the teacher says i need to talk to
you because your son
coughed
in class
and we're pretty sure it was on purpose
but if this continues
um if there is a third offense
then suspension or expulsion may be next
as outlined by the district's student
handbook upon further incidents
now um
will we reach a point where a serial
coffer might actually be expelled yes we
can count on it
because a certain madness has gripped
hold of a large portion of the country
and there is no ceiling to this
craziness or perhaps i should say
there's no basement no floor we're going
to keep plunging because fearful people
are capable of just about anything
i witnessed this myself last night as i
attended the metro nashville school
board meeting to lend my support to
these sane parents who don't want to
muzzle their kids for eight hours a day
and also to make my own voice heard now
i should acknowledge at the outset that
yes
i homeschool my kids they aren't setting
foot inside a public school especially
not after what i witnessed last night
but my money attends public schools in
this town i pay for them and so the
school's policies are very much my
business also i care about the
mistreatment of children even if they
are not my own imagine that
that's why i talk about issues like
abortion and the trans indoctrination of
kids and so on my kids aren't going to
be subjected to any of that either and
yet i still speak because these kids who
are subjected to it can't speak for
themselves
and need all the advocates they can get
now i've nonetheless been criticized for
daring to speak at the school board when
my kids don't attend but i've got news
for you this wasn't the last time
i kind of enjoyed it so they're going to
be hearing from me again and i can tell
you that and next time maybe i'll bring
three or four hundred friends along with
me
the public school system is a government
institution and i am a taxpayer which
means i get to make my voice heard and i
will repeatedly and loudly
and i certainly won't put my kids in the
middle of this lunacy just so that i can
have the right to do so
also note something else many of the
loudest voices in the country calling
for kids to be masked in public school
certainly do not send their kids to
public school many of them don't even
have kids
many of the loudest voices in the
country calling for masks in general
don't wear them themselves as we've seen
if they can get involved and have a say
so can i and so can you
now with that out of the way
back to the school board meeting
yesterday was in fact a big day for
school boards in the greater nashville
area south of here in williamson county
there was a
huge turnout of largely anti-mass
mandate people
many of them rallying outside in
addition to the hundreds of people
inside many spoke out against the
mandates there including clay travis he
was there based on what i saw on social
media and the news reports it seems that
it was a pretty inspiring turnout as
sanity outweighed insanity in williamson
county that is sanity outweighed
insanity
among the people
just not on the school board itself
unfortunately which still voted seven to
three to mandate the masks anyway
but that shouldn't be the end of the
discussion
the pressure should stay on these people
for as long as the masks are on the kids
now at our meeting the scene was a
little bit different
the board had already instated the mask
mandate before the public meeting
yesterday
they met last week and then stated it
and then they had the meeting
a sizable group of people showed up to
represent the pro-freedom pro sanity
side but
this is downtown nashville which means
we had a large group of pro-mass mandate
parents and teachers um who who were
there in attendance uh and there were
other markers to other signifiers
showing what we were up against like for
example the rainbow flags decorating the
boardroom and even adorning the uniforms
of the security guards don't worry
though they did have the latest and most
inclusive and also ugliest rainbow flag
prominently displaying their special
support for the trans community
now the rainbow flag is of course a
leftist religious icon and has no place
in any school building or government
building of any kind separation of
church and state isn't that what we're
always told but that's a problem we'll
have to tackle another day
and we will by the way
the public comments began with a whole
series of pro-mask mandate parents
many of these people were i can tell you
hysterical
completely hysterical
listening to these parents defending the
mask man many of them tearfully thanking
the school board for imposing it
thank you for saving my kids with tears
in their eyes i'm not exaggerating
and watching this what jumped out at me
of course was the was was the fear
i mean they were sometimes literally
trembling in terror
deathly afraid that their children would
die from a virus that has killed point
.008 percent of the 42 million children
it has infected a mortality rate so low
that it simply is not rational to worry
about it
i tried to make that point when it was
my time to speak uh we'll play some of
that for you now
and by the way the the city has not
posted the video of the meeting yet so
we had we had to make do with the cell
phone video my producer sean took the
audio isn't the best but bear with us um
and uh here it
board have decided is our kids should go
to school all day every day wearing
muzzles like rabid dogs i have listened
to your arguments and i've noticed that
they're missing a few things namely
evidence data science common sense and
basic human thesis
you presented no facts at all uh so let
me do that now here they are code poses
almost no risk to our kids at all 4.2
million children have tested positive
for coping a total of 0.008 percent of
them have done what about the flu the
cdc estimates that 480 kids died from
the flu in the 2018-2019 season that's
more than a diet from kobe in a year and
a half now did anyone on this board
suggest at any point that year that kids
wear masks did anyone in this room
suggest that at any point anyone wear
masks for flu which again is more
dangerous to kids than kobe that's a
fact
[Applause]
do you know what it's called when you
force your children to wear masks for
fear of a virus that poses almost no
threat to them it's called child abuse
you want to look up a disease look up
1000 byproxy because that's what this is
now do any of you know what sort of
psychological damage we do to children
by forcing them to cover their faces
teaching them that the air is toxic that
everyone around them is sick
deprive them of the ability to see each
other's faces do you know what kind of
damage that that does have you thought
about it have you wondered about the
health effects of forcing kids to
breathe through sweat and spit and dirt
soaked rags every single day are you
sure that there are no health risks
do you know what the effect is on
children developmentally
if they're not able to read each other's
facial cues what about learning to read
and they can't see the teacher
enunciating the words
what does it do to a child's developing
immune system if you have to wear a mask
all day every day you're satisfied to
place this burden on children anyway and
why it's not to keep them safe it's not
to keep the adults safe they can all get
vaccinated if they want no you do it to
make yourselves feel better and to
protect yourselves politically the
child's past is a symbolic security
[Applause]
it's a disgrace you should all be
ashamed
[Applause]
you know that guy raises some good
points
and uh pretty good looking guy too if i
have to if i do say so myself hit it
right there at the buzzer uh and that
was the the main thing i was uh the most
proud of they they give you three
minutes and they're pretty strict about
it so right at the buzzer
that's how you do it ladies and
gentlemen now
um the point about the flu has been made
many times but we should keep making it
uh and i wasn't the only person by the
way in in the crowd there
to uh to bring up this issue of the flu
um because perhaps more than any other
point it reveals how completely
irrational our approach to covet has
been it's not that there was less
masking during flu seasons in the past
or even that people called for basking
but never succeeded in getting the
policies put in place until covet you
know
no that's not what happened
nobody ever considered it it was not an
option on the table
nobody ever brought it up the people who
are now saying you're going to kill my
child if you don't wear a mask
none of them not one ever said anything
during flu season
that's because although the flu is a
greater danger to kids
there was never any campaign to make us
afraid of it we were all concerned about
the flu cautious about it to a certain
extent
um we obviously didn't want to
get the flu or we didn't want to we
certainly don't want our kids to get it
when i got a terrible case of the flu
about a year and a half ago which now on
second thought i think was probably
covered but at the time we thought it
was was the flu
and um
and we had a newborn in the house
and it was a you know and i was very
very sick for about three or four days
and i quarantined myself
in a room and basically didn't leave it
because i especially didn't want the
baby to get the flu because that could
be
really fatal
um the point is i didn't need anyone to
tell me that i didn't need i didn't i
didn't need to look at any guidance
guidance from the cdc
i didn't need a year and a half of
lecturing i just knew to do that because
i'm a rational person and i don't want
my kids to get sick
but even though we were concerned about
the flu we don't want our kids to get it
we maintained a proper perspective about
it and we continued living our lives
many people as i witnessed myself
firsthand last night have lost their
ability to do that
with covid
completely lost it
i mean lost it in like every sense of
the word
one i'm telling you one parent after
another losing it
barely able to speak because they're so
afraid
overwhelmed by their own fear
fear is dependent fear is the pandemic
now
it is the virus
and notice something
it's the average citizen
it's the parent of the school child who
trembles in fear who literally cries to
the school board that she's afraid her
child will die the people putting these
policies in place the powers that be
they're not trembling
that's because they're not afraid
they know better
but they want you to be afraid because
your fear is the greatest gift to them
your fear makes you easy to control to
manipulate to persuade of anything
a fearful populace is a subjugated
populace fearful people become willful
slaves
roosevelt might have been onto something
after all
sounds like cliche now but it's true
there's nothing to fear but fear itself
and that has never been more true than
it is today
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now i thank you for your
compliance it is
somewhat appreciated